- Got on the elevator in L.A.
one day and the lady said,
Oh, I just saw you in
the Hudsucker Reduction.
I had a long haul, from where I came from
to here, but here we are.
Your job as an actor is to give it
your best shot, every time.
So, there was a period,
there in the early 80's,
when I didn't get any work
because I would ask these questions.
- He's an American actor,
producer and narrator.
He is known for his distinctively
smooth, and deep voice.
He's ranked as the third
highest box office star
with over 4.3 billion
dollars in box office gross.
He's Morgan Freeman and
here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
- To collect unemployment,
you have to go out
and hunt for employment.
You have a code and
mine was a clerk typist;
so, you go out and you look
for work as a clerk typist.
And one day, I just,
I can't keep being forced
to be a clerk typist.
So, I went to the employment office
and I asked to see the supervisor.
And I was lead into this
office, this pretty little lady,
redhead, whose name was Mrs.
Lipton, what can I do for you?
And I said, you're forcing
me to be something I'm not.
I have to go out and look
for work as a clerk typist,
I'm not a clerk typist, I'm an actor.
So, I just can't keep doing it this way.
She took this thing and
stamped my employment book,
and said you've got six
months, go be an actor.
So, if Mrs. Lipton is alive today,
Mrs. Lipton, I'm an actor.
The box office success when
The Shawshank Redemption
came out was Dumb and Dumber.
(crowd laughing)
- I'm just not going to laugh.
- Well, no, but that's,
you know, the juxtaposition
of box office and, what's
that other term, critical.
Shawshank got really good reviews,
but because nobody could
say Shawshank Redemption,
it didn't get word of mouth.
And I don't care how
much you promote a film,
if you don't have word of
mouth, you aint promoting it.
People have to be able
to go and say, listen,
I saw this really terrific
film, it was called,
(crowd laughing)
Shanksham--
Shimshunk--
(crowd laughing)
Got on the elevator in L.A.
one day and the lady said,
Oh, I just saw you in
the Hudsucker Reduction.
(crowd laughing)
So, that was the reason it
was not a box office success.
No word of mouth at all.
- [Don] Here's a stat from your show,
and it says that the richest
85 people on this planet
have as much money as
the poorest 3.5 billion.
- Yeah, right, that's
on the planet however.
You know, that's--
- [Don] It's not far off here in America.
- No it isn't far off in America,
but we still hear, don't abandon
the idea that it isn't finite.
It isn't finite if you were born,
where were you born?
- Me?
- Yeah, you.
- Baton Rouge, Louisiana,
Baton Rouge General Hospital.
- Baton Rouge, Louisiana, I
was born in Memphis, Tennessee.
I had a long haul from
where I came from to here,
but here we are.
- [Don] Right.
- So, proof is in, the
proof of the pudding
is in the eating and here
we sit at the dining table.
- But it's hard to, when
you say that to some people,
because they say, well,
there you go with the pull
yourself up by the bootstraps
thing, and, you know,
you're just being respectable.
Not everybody can do that.
- Bull (beeps), everybody can.
Everybody doesn't.
Courage, courage is
the key to life itself.
There are a lot of people
who are born in situations
where they say, well, I'll
never get out of this,
so, they won't.
I say to people who say, well,
I would like to have done
so and so, so and so, and I
say, well, you could've done it.
They say, well, I couldn't
get out of here, well,
man, the bus runs every day.
(laughing)
- You're exactly right.
- Yeah.
- If you can conceive it in your mind,
- If you can think of it, you can do it,
that's the human condition,
if we can imagine it,
we can do it.
- [Don] Right.
- And I think that's the condition
of each individual human.
Your job as an actor is
to give it your best shot
every time, so, yes, I'm
going into it with the idea
that I'll play it to
the best of my ability
and they wouldn't give it to me, the role,
if they didn't think I was
capable of pulling it off,
or, I wouldn't take it if I didn't think
I was capable of pulling it off.
- So what advice would you
give purely in an acting sense,
to yourself, 30, 40 years ago?
- Same advice I gave myself
30, 40 years ago, get a job.
(laughing)
Act.
There are, unfortunately,
those of us who say,
well, I want to be a star,
that's way out there
in the ether somewhere.
I want to be a working
actor, you can pull that off.
So, act, work, work.
Someone asked me once,
and you're about to do it,
(laughing)
what would you do if you weren't an actor?
If you didn't make it as an
actor, what would you do?
I have no idea, I would act somewhere.
Maybe I'd be driving a cab,
maybe I'm working somebody's yard,
whatever I'm doing, I'm
going to belong to somebody's
little theater group, I will act,
cause I'll die if I don't.
I got into the air force because I was,
as it turns out, I was
romanticizing that whole idea,
you know, we were re-fighting World War II
as I was growing up, so, we
had all these heroic movies,
and I fell in love with
the idea of flying.
And, then, when I got into the air force,
I had this big eye opener,
that racism was rampant there also,
and that I didn't,
I am not as qualified or as
suited, is a better word,
for military life, that kind of,
unquestioning obedience to a lot of things
that I think are stupid,
didn't quite go over well.
(laughs)
So, when I got out I
was an early discharge.
It was almost dishonorable you know,
cause I just really didn't fit
but the catalyst, actually,
was I did get to sit in a jet trainer
cause I had a lot of people
behind me to get me into
flight school and stuff,
but sitting there, it occurred to me
that this is absolutely not what I want.
It isn't movies, it's for real, you know,
this little red button
on the joystick controls
guns with real bullets.
I sat there for quite a while and knew
that if I made a strafing
run, I needed a camera here,
and I needed the people
to be able to get up
and go back to number one.
(laughs)
So, I got out of that
plane, on the runway,
at North Island Air Station,
a Naval air station,
and I walked away from
that and towards acting.
I knew that it was all about the movies.
It was all about the movies.
I got on stage the very first time
when I was eight years
old, I was brilliant.
Then, I got on stage
again four years later,
when I was 12, brilliant again.
So, by the time I was
13, it was pretty much
a foregone conclusion in
everybody's else's mind,
teachers, parents, that acting
was going to be my thing.
I hadn't, like made a conscious decision
that I'm going to be an actor,
I don't think you do, I think you just,
that's what you do.
The first stage play I did in New York,
I was working with Stacy
Keach in Viveca Lindfors',
that was a great experience for me.
You talk about a masterclass,
you have it there.
Stacy had come out of
Yale University, I think,
and he was much more
advanced as a stage actor
than I was, but wow, did I have big ears,
and was I ready to learn;
so, you just sit and watch.
It's always a learning experience.
The big thing I learned from
working with Pearl Bailey was
professionalism, she was
a total professional,
total, total, total professional.
She always gave 100 percent,
110 percent in a performance.
And I watched her very carefully.
She was one of those performers
that you say, this is the way to go,
this is the way to be,
in this business.
Be on time, know what you're doing,
do it full out, give all
you can, that's a lesson.
As I said, I went to
the movies all the time.
I've seen the movies, and at some point
it struck me rather dramatically,
how much I wasn't in the movies.
Not the way I needed to be in the movies.
And, if you look at a lot
of the disaster movies
in that period, the only
people left on the planet
were white, so, now, my thing is
if I get in the movies,
I want to make sure,
that I speak about that.
That if I am able to do it,
I want to talk about it.
So, there was a period
there in the early 80's,
when I didn't get any work
because I would ask these questions.
I auditioned, oh, I don't
think I even got to audition,
I interviewed for the movie,
The Thing, the remake.
So, I read the script, and
I go back for the audition,
and the producer or the
director, one of those,
said, did you read the
script, I said, yes.
What did you think?
I said, well, you've got 11
people at the South Pole,
eight of them are scientists,
and then you have a cook,
a mechanic and something
else, they're all black,
none of the scientists are.
What do you think I think?
Needless to say, I didn't
get that job. (laughs)
Again though, you know, providence
rears her beautiful head,
when Glory came about.
I was just floored, cause I knew about
the 54th Massachusetts
Regiment from a one page thing
on This Day in History in Jet Magazine.
She talked about this
Sergeant who was awarded a
Medal of Honor for his
activities at this charge
with this outfit.
So, the history is there,
it's there to draw upon.
But, we could ask ourselves,
we, me, black people,
why aren't we, why don't
we figure more in it?
I need something that's
going to engage me,
that makes me sit up and think.
I refuse to take part in anything
that is going to denigrate a people.
(soft orchestral music)
Especially me.
(audience cheers)
- [Jimmy] Alright, here we go, ready?
Do you ever want to go to space?
(audience laughs)
- I really shouldn't be doing this.
(Jimmy laughs)
- It's helium, it's helium,
Morgan, it is helium.
- It's very undignified.
- (laughing) I think
your voice sounds great,
it's not undignified.
Some people just have voices like this
so you're actually making
fun of those people.
- See.
(audience laughs)
I told you.
- I want to thank you
so much for being on the show,
and, please, would you
ever like to come back?
- I'm never coming back.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
JP Annett asked me to,
so, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what you learned most
from Morgan Freeman, which of the 10 clips
had the biggest impact to you and why,
what change are you going
to make in your business
or life as a result of
watching this video?
What's the impact?
Leave it in the comments below
and I will join the discussion.
Finally, I want to give
a quick shout out to
Kris Schantz from www.happyworker.com.
Kris, thank you so much
for picking up my book,
it really means a lot to me.
For those of you watching,
if you want a chance
at a shout out in a future video,
make sure to grab the book
and also email in your
receipts so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
continue to believe or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.